okay hi everyone I'll be started okay so it's Tuesday of week two so hopefully that means everyone has done the assignment one everyone done assignment one um you know uh I'm if I'm saying this I'm probably saying it to the wrong people but it it seems like every year some people blow some of their um late days on assignment one and it's really just the wrong place to use them um so yeah hopefully you've all done assignment one um and did not that this is meant to be the easy onramp um and
then we go straight on from that so that out today we have assignment two so assignment two um has two purposes um purpose one is to make you do some math um to um some understanding of what newal networks really compute and how they compute it and that's what I'm going to talk about today is also going through that math um but then simultaneously maybe it does three things in assignment two um so we're going to be learning something about dependency paing which will be actually something about um language structure
and Linguistics but then thirdly um for assignment two we're going to start using pytorch so pytorch is is one of the leading software Frameworks for deep learning and the one that we're going to um use for this class um so for p i mean the assignment 3 pytorch is exceedingly um scaffolded so it's sort of you know here's this thing and you have to write these two lines use these two functions um but nevertheless um for help people get up to speed and get started using pytorch on Friday at 3:30
in Gates bo1 or it will again be recorded um we have a tutorial on pytorch and so that's a great way to get more of a sense of py torch and how it works before doing assignment two um yeah uh the other things yeah so for nearly all the lectures we've got um further reading of places that you can look um of all the classes in the attire um this um for many people might be a really good one to look at the suggested readings we have several readings which are sort of shorter tutorials and reviews of the kind of um Matrix
calculus um and linear algebra that we need for this class um so really encourage you um to look at those um if you decide that one is your favorite you can tell us on Ed which one you think is the best one to choose between between them I kind of like the one that's first on the list but maybe you'll feel differently um yeah um conversely um yeah so today will be sort of all math and then Thursday will be kind of all language and Linguistics some people find the language and Linguistics hard
as well um so I guess different kinds of people um okay so getting straight into it um so where we started last time um I'd sort of shown these baby neural networks and sort of said well we can think of each of those orange things as basically like a little logistic regression unit and the crucial difference from then the kind of um statistics machine learning you see in a stats class 109 or wherever is that in those you have one logistic regression and you're defining the input features
to it and you've got some decision variable that you want to un have at the output here you're sort of building these Cascades of little logistic regressions and so the idea is right at the end we're going to Define what we want we're going to capture that by our objective function or loss function but for the stuff in the middle that that stuff in the middle is going to be a chance for the neural network to learn by itself what would be useful inputs to further Downstream neurons what kind of
functions should I come up with in terms of my inputs that will help me provide um useful outputs to help the final computation down the track um and you know if you haven't sort of seen and um thought about this much before I mean I think you know it's worth uh sitting with that idea for a moment CU this is really a super powerful idea which is what's made neural networks more powerful in most circumstances than other forms of machine learning the fact that you have this self-organization of intermediate levels
of representation that you use to compute things that will be useful Downstream for what you eventually want to do um the other reason I was bring back up this picture is I've sort of wanted to go straight from here um to matric um so while you could sort of wire together neurons however you wanted to and arguably if you look at human brains they look more like neurons wired together however you wanted to but for what's done with neural networks basically there's always this kind of
regular structure of layers so once we have this regular structure of layers we are taking um the output of one of our neurons at one layer and we're feeding them together with weights um to produce um the inputs to the next layer so we're taking the X1 X2 X3 outputs we're multiplying them all by weights we're adding a bias term um and then we're going to put it through a nonlinearity and that will give us the value at the next layer so if we then kind of collapse that to a vector and this to a vector
that then collapses into a computation that first of all we're doing a matrix multiplication we're calculating WX of the inputs and then we're adding on the biases as a a vector of biases which gives us this intermediate value Z and then we have this nonlinearity or activation function which is applied um to that which gives us the values in the next layer of the new Network and the activation function is applied to a vector and produces a vector but it's operating on each of the individual
components of that Vector one at a time so we've got some Scala function that we're just applying to each element of the vector um and so that's the kind of picture um we saw when I did this example and I'm going to continue to use this example in today's class remember we were going to decide whether the word in the middle of the input window was a location or not and so we were doing the matrix multiplication putting it through the nonlinearity we're then just doing a DOT product here and then we're going
that got stuck into um uh sigmoid um to predict yes or no um and the final thing I wanted to say a little bit about is these FS the nonlinearity or the activation function and where did they come in well the starting point of where they came in in the history of newal networks is when people came up with this idea that well you could represent um the operation of a basic neuron by doing a matrix multiplication of the inputs and then having a bias term or here represents a threshold term to see whether the
neurons should fire or not that was actually in the very first implementation which B dates back to the 1940s as done as a threshold right so that if um the activation was greater than Theta you output one otherwise you output zero and well if you have a threshold um the the two lines are flat right so there is no slope there is no gradient um so that's actually makes learning much harder so the whole secret of what we build with newal networks and in an alternative name that's um popular
in some circles these days is gradient-based learning and the entire idea of gradient based learning is if we actually have some slopes um then it's like going skiing during spring break you can work out where it's steeper and you can head down where it's steeper um and that will allow us to op imiz our function to learn much more quickly and so that's one reason that we don't just want to have threshold units we want to have things with slopes so we um have gradient so in subsequent work people
started using activation functions with slopes um and so the first popular one um was this sigmoidal logistic that we've seen for mapping to probabilities but you know it's sort of imperfect it seemed because you know the output was always non- negative so that sort of tends to push things towards bigger numbers so um there was quite a bit of use then of this tan H function um and you'll actually see tan H when we do assignment three we'll be using tan H's in our current new networks um and so um
I've written there um the formula usually give for Tan H in terms of exponentials um yeah if your math is Rusty it's not obvious that tan H and logistic have much to do with each other um but if you want to treat this as a math problem um that a 10 H is literally just a rescaled logistic you're stretching it by two and moving it down by one it's the same function um okay um but you know so that's nice but if you're calculating 10 hes you have to do all of these exponentials and
you know exponentials are kind of slow on your computer and things like that you might wonder whether you couldn't get away with something much cheaper and so people thought about that and thought oh maybe we could just use a so-called hard tan H um where it has a slope of one in the middle and is then just flat outside that area and you know that seemed to work in many cases and so that then led to the popularity of the rectified linear unit um so the rectified linear unit is simply zero on
the negative region and then is yal x in the positive region now this seems kind of wonky and goes against what I was saying about gradient based learning because once you're in the negative region there's no gradient um you're just dead um but in the positive region there is gradient and the gradient is particularly simple right the slope is always one um and so you know this still feels slightly perverse to me but you know this really became the norm of what people use for a number of years because
people found that although for an individual neuron it was dead half the time anytime it went negative that overall for your newal network some things would be alive so it kind of gave sort of a form of specializ ation and the fact that the slope was always one meant that you got um really easy productive backward flow of gradients in a way we'll talk about later and so um learning with realu turned to be out to be very effective and people started using the realu nonlinearity everywhere and it sort of became the default in the
norm and you'll see us using it in the assignments in particular we use it in assignment to and so get to see that it works but nevertheless at some point people sort of had second thoughts and decided you know having a dead over half of its range maybe isn't such a good idea after all even though it seemed to work great for a few years and so a lot of what's happened since then is then to come up with other functions which are in some sense Ru like but not actually dead um so um um
okay I don't really yeah uh here we go enough so one one version of that is the socalled Leaky value so for the Leaky value you make the negative half a straight line as well with a very minor slope but still it's got a little bit of slope um there is then a variant of that called the parametric value where you have one extra parameter which is actually what the slope of the ne the negative part is and people showed some positive result with that um more recently again and this is what you
often see in recent Transformer models um is you see um nonlinearities like Swiss swis and Jello so both of these are sort of fancy functions but kind of what they both look like is basically this is yal X to all intense and purposes not quite but approximately and then you got sort of some funky bit of curve down here which again gives you a bit of slope um it's sort of the curve is going the opposite way that's sort of a bit funny but they seem to work well commonly used um in recent Transformer
models um so you know that's a bit of a dump of all the nonlinearities people use I mean the details of that aren't super important right now but the important thing to um have in your head is why do we need nonlinearities and the way to think about about that is that what we're doing with neural networks is function approximation there's some very complex function that we want to learn you know like maybe we want to go from a piece of text to its meaning or we want to be interpreting visual scenes or
something like that um and so we want to build really good function approximators and well if you're just doing Matrix multiplies a matrix multiply of a vector is a linear transform so that doesn't let you multiply complex functions I guess strictly if you put a bias on the end it's then an aine transform but let's keep it simple linear transforms right so if you're doing multiple if you're doing multiple Matrix multiplies you're doing multiple linear transforms but they compose so you could have just
multiplied these two matrices together and you'd have a single linear transform so you get no power in terms of representation by having multi-layer networks that are just Matrix multiplies you know as in a little aside in terms of representational power having multi-layer Matrix multiplies gives you no power but if you think about in terms of learning actually it does give you some power so in the theoretical Community looking at newal networks there actually quite a few papers that look at linear newal networks meaning
that they're just sequences of the multiplies with no nonlinearities because they have interesting learning properties even though they give you no representational power um okay but we'd like to be able to learn functions like this not only functions like this and to be able to learn functions like this we need more than linear transforms and we achieve those by having something that makes us be calculating a nonlinear function and it's these activation functions that give us nonlinear
functions okay cool um okay so then getting on to today so the whole thing we want to do now is gradient based learning right this is our stochastic gradient thecenter equation where here you know that upside down triangle symbol right that's our gradient we're wanting to work out the slope of our objective function and so this is how we're going to learn by calculating gradients so what we want to know is how do we calculate the gradients for an arbitrary function and so what I want to do today is first of
all do this by hand um for math um and then discuss you know how do we do it computationally um which is effectively um the famous thing that's taken as powering um underpowering all of neuron Nets which is the back propagation algorithm but the back propagation algorithm is just automating the math okay and so for the math it's Matrix calculus and at this point then there's a huge Spectrum um between people who know much more math than me and people who barely ever learned this um but you
know uh I hope to explain the essentials um or remind people of them um enough that you're at least at a starting point um for reading some other stuff and doing homework too so um let's get into that and so I'm going to spend about half the time on those two halves um and you know the hope is that after this you'll feel like oh I actually understand how new networks work under the hood fingers crossed okay so here we go so if you're a Stanford student um you maybe did math 51 um or else you could have done math
51 which teaches linear algebra multivariate calculus and modern applications um math 51 covers every everything I'm going to talk about and way more stuff so if you actually know that and remember it you can um look at Instagram for the next 35 minutes um but I think the problem is um that you know quite apart from the fact a lot of people do it as Frost um you know this is a lot to get through in 10 weeks and I think that a lot of the people who do this class sort of by two years later don't really have much ability to use
any of it um but you know if you actually looked at this book really Harden for a very really long time you would have discovered that actually right towards the end of the book in appendix G um there's actually an appendix on newal networks and the multivariable chain roll which is precisely what we're going to be using um for um doing our neural networks um but there are only two problems one problem is that this is Page 697 of the book and I'm not sure anyone ever gets that far and the problem is even if you
do get that far you know I don't know I find these pages that they're really dense texty Pages it's not even easy to understand them if you have gone there so here's my attempt on that um so the Mantra to have in your head is G if I can remember basic single variable calculus you know that I've got 3x squ and the derivative of that is 6X that's all you sort of need to know right the ENT is multivariable calculus is just like single variable calculus except you're using
matrices okay so that's our article of faith and we're going to do that and so what we're wanting to do is to do Matrix calculus or the generalization of that tensor calculus sort of using um vectors matrices and higher order tensors because if we can do things and what's referred to as vectorized gradients in the neural network world that that will be sort of the fast efficient way to do our operations you know so if you want to think it all through you can do it single variable at a time and check that
you're doing the right thing and I sort of tried to indicate that in the first lecture but if we want to have our networks go room we want to be doing Matrix calculus okay so let's work up to doing that okay so this is the part that I I trust everyone can remember right so we have f ofx = x cubed and we can do single variable um derivative and the derivative is 3x² everyone remember that one okay that's something we can all start from and remember this derivative is saying the slope of things right so the slope
of things lets us work out where is something steep so we'll be able to go skiing right that's our goal right and so you can think of the slope of things as how much the output will change if we change the input a bit right that's our measure of um steepness right so um that so since the derivative is 3x^2 if we're at x = 1 that means the slope is about 3 * 1 S 3 so if I work out the value of the function for 1.01 it's gone up by about three times point I move the X by 0.01 and the output moved by 0.03 where
if I go to x = 4 the derivative is 3 * 4^2 is 48 and so if I work out the value of the function at 4.01 I get approximately 64.4 versus 64 right that small difference from 4 to 4.01 has been magnified 48 times in the output okay okay so now we just uh remember the Mantra it's going to be exactly the same single value calculus um but with more stuff so if we have a function with n inputs we're then going to work out its gradient um which is its partial derivative with respect to each input so
its gradient will now be a vector of the same size as the number of inputs um and there's this funky symb um which people pronounce various ways I mean you know this kind of originated some kind of someone's weird way of drawing a calligraphic d right so it is really a D um so I think I'll mainly just call it D but sometimes people call it partial or funy D or some some other name right so you have DF dx1 DF dx2 for each of the variables okay so if we go beyond that um and then have a function
with um n inputs and M outputs what we then get for um the gradient is what's referred to as the Jacobian now actually um the dude this is named after was a German Jew so it should really be yakobi um but no one says that in this country um Jacobian um okay so the Jacobian is then a matrix of partial derivatives um where you're working out for each output and each input the partial derivative between the component of the input and the output so this looks like the kind of thing that we're
going to have when we have a neural network layer because we're going to have um n inputs and M outputs for the two layers of our neural networks so we'll be using these kind of jacobians okay um so then you know the whole idea of newal networks is we've got these multi-level computations and they're going to correspond to composition of functions so we need to know how to compose things both for calculating functions and for calculating their gradients so if we have a one variable function and we want
to um work out um its derivative in terms of a composition of two functions what we're doing is multiplying um our computations okay so um if you compose together um Z of Y um that's the function that we did at the beginning that gives you oh was it no it's not sorry it's different okay Z of Y gives you 3x2 right and so we know that the derivative of that is um 6X okay if we do it in terms of the pieces we can work out DZ Dy um which is just going to be three and um Dy DX is 2X and we can work out
the total derivative by multiplying these two pieces and we get 6X the same answer right um so um Matrix calculus is exactly like single variable calculus except we're using um tensors of different um so the word tensor is used to mean as you go up that Spectrum in in its size so from sort of Scala to Vector to Matrix to then you know what in computer science is normally still uh is multidimensional arrays um that spectrum is then tensors of different um Dimensions okay so um when we have multiple variable functions we're going
to multiply jacobians so here we have a function WX + B and then we um compose um the nonlinearity F to get H and so we're going to be able to compute that in the same way as a product of these partial derivatives which are jacobians okay so let's start looking at a few examples of what we get so let's count with start with an element wise activation function so when we have a a vector that's being calculated as the activation function of a previously computed quantity well we're Computing
that component wise as I explained before so hi equals F of Z and where the sort of f is our activation function that actually applies to a scalar but you know overall this layer is a function with n outputs and N inputs and so it's going to have an N by n Jacobian and well what that's going to so this is our definition of the Jacobian um but in this case this is sort of a special case because if I equals J um then we're going to have um the output um J the HJ depending on Z and otherwise
it's going to be zero CU for the off diagonal entries it doesn't matter how you change the value it's not changing the output because the output only depends on the corresponding index and so what we're going to get for this Jacobian of activation functions is a matrix where everything is zero apart from the diagonal terms um that correspond to where we're calculating the activation function and for those ones we're going to have to work out how to compute the derivative of our
activation function that was on assignment one one of the questions on assignment one I do believe or or was it on assignment two no no it's assignment two one of the questions on assignment two I got that wrong one of the ones on the new assignment is say hey um can you work out um the derivative of a logistic function well then we'd be a to plug that straight into um fpre so I'm not going to give that answer away today um okay so um other things that we want to do um with uh Jacobian is well we have
this um layer of our neural network where we're um calculating WX + B and we can want to work out the partial derivative of that with respect to X um you know this is the kind of place where it actually works to remember the Mantra and say Matrix calculus is just like single value variable calculus but with matrices so if you just don't use your bra too hard and think oh it's just like single variable calculus so what should the answer be it's obviously going to be W right and indeed it is um similarly if
we want to do the same thing for wxb and work out the partial derivative with respect to B um well that would be one in terms of single variable calculus and so in Matrix calculus that becomes an identity Matrix okay slightly different the same idea um but that's reflecting the fact that b is actually Vector so we need we need it to be coming out um as an identity Matrix um okay so um higher up in my example picture I did this sort of vector um do product of UT um and well what happens if we work
out the um the um to C in of that what we end up with strict ly is we come out with HT um and you know this is sort of like when you're working out um well we did this in the first class right when we did a a DOT product calculation that you kind of get for each individual element you get the opposite term and so you get um the other Vector coming out um these are sort of good ones to comput it at home for practice to make sure um you really do know the answers and why they work out the way they
do okay um so let's go back to our little neural net um this was most of our neural net up above our neural net um there was the nonlinearity now I'm going to uh leave that out of this time oh see I got it wrong it's on assignment two um but you know normally you'd be C calculating the partials of the output the loss function with respect to the inputs but since the loss function is On Assignment two I'm going to leave that out and I'm just going to calculate derivatives with
respect to this score that feeds into the loss function so we first we got um the newal network layer the nonlinearity and then we're doing this dot product to work out a score for each position which feeds into the logistic function so if you want to work out ddb um so that's with respect to the bias for first so the way we do it is you know we break up our equations into our individual pieces that are composed together and so that means we break this up so we first calculate the zal WX + B
then we apply the activation function to the different components okay then after that um what we remember to do is okay to work out um our um partial derivatives of B of s with respect to B that what we're going to be doing is doing the product of um the partial derivatives of the component pieces so we're applying um The Matrix calculus version of the chain rule so dsdb equals D sdh * DHD Z * dzb um and which corresponds to these three layers that are composed together and so at that point um we remember our
useful jacobians from the previous slide and we can just apply them so the top one um DSD is um the you transpose or else or maybe it's you let's come back to that there's a fine point on that that I will explain more about later um um okay um then for the DH DZ that was the activation function where we got the diagonal of um the derivative of f of Z and then for dzdb that's where we got the identity function okay um so we can simplify that down and so what that's going to end up as is the UT transpose
that funny symbol there times the um the vector element y's um derivative of f um this symbol which doesn't normally turn up um in your regular math course but turns up all the time in New networks is referred to as the Hadad product and the Hadad product is meaning element wise multiplication so it's not like a cross product where you put two vectors together and you get out one number of Scala you put two vectors together you element wise multiply them all and you're left with another Vector of the
same type okay so that so now this gave us are working out of the partials of dstb and for a neural network um we want to work out all the other partials as well so overall here in the picture right we had the X the W the B um and the U and we'd like to work out partials with respect to all of those variables so we can change their values and learn so that our model predicts better um so um so suppose we now want to um calculate ddw so again we can split it up with the same chain Rule and say
ddw equals the product of these three things and the important thing to notice is that two of those three things were exactly the same ones that we calculated before the only bit that's different is that at the end we're now doing DZ DW rather than dzdb and so the first central idea that we'll come back to when we do computation graphs is oh we really want to avoid doing repeated work so we want to realize that those two parts of things are the same and since we're just sort of multiplying these um partial
derivatives together right we can just compute what that part is and reuse it and so if we want to um wait yeah okay so if we're wanting to calculate ddw the part that's the same this part here we can refer to as Delta so Delta is sort of the Upstream gradient or the error signal the part that you've got from sort of starting at the beginning DS DH DH DZ this sort of shared Upstream part we can calculate that once and then we can use it um to calculate both of these two things and for dsdb because
the dzdb just comes out as the identity Matrix um the answer is just Delta but for D sdw we need to work out the DZ DW before we're finished okay so what um does what do we get for that last piece so one question you might start off with and is normally a good thing to think about when you're doing assignment problems on this and other things is the first thing to think about is you know what do things look like like am I should the answer be a vector a matrix uh what size should it be and things like that so for
ddw um W is an N bym Matrix um and S is a scalar so therefore since we have one output and M * m inputs the answer according to math should be that we've got a one by n * m Jacobian I a big long row Vector um but here's where um things get a teeny bit tricky um and there's sort of we end up with this weird mess of um math and Engineering convenience because you know immediately what we're wanting to do is we're wanting to take our old parameters which will be in stored in the form of
matrices vectors and so on that we're using as coefficients and we're going to want to subtract from them um our you know a fraction of our calculated gradient so what we'd like to do is have our um calculated gradients in the same shapes as our parameters because then we can just do subtraction whereas if they've turned into a God Almighty row Vector um that's not quite so convenient um so it turns out that what we end up doing um is using something that gets referred to as the shape convention that
um we uh uh reshape our um jacobians so they fit into things that are of the same shape as the parameters that we are using so we're going to represent um DSD W as an N bym Matrix laid out as follows and that's a place that one people can get confused okay so that's what we want to calculate that kind of Matrix but um and so that Matrix is going to be Delta * DZ DW so Delta is going to be part of the answer and then we want to know um what DZ DW is um and the answer is going to be it's going to come out like this so D
sdw is going to be um delta T * XT so it's going to be the product of the Upstream gradient which was the same thing we calculated before for the other two quantities and then a local inputs symbol which um is input signal which is here coming out to XT okay um and you know so we're taking the transposes of those two vectors which it means that we end up calculating an outer product of those two vectors um which gives us our gradient um and so why is that the right answer well you know it kind of looks
convenient CU that's giving us something of the right shape um for what I was arguing we want to find out and we have the right number of terms um now I'm going to rush through this so I encourage you to read um the uh lecture notes and do this more carefully but um let me at least a little bit explain why it makes sense right so um if you think of one weight um in so all of these connections are our Matrix right The Matrix is being represented by all these lines and in your network so if you
think of one number in The Matrix so here is w23 so it's connecting from input 3 or it's multiplying input three to give part of the answer of H2 right so it's this line here um so for this line here um this weight is being used only in the calculation of H2 and the only thing it's dependent on is X3 um so that if you're then wanting to work out the partial of um h two um or Z2 sorry yeah um sorry yeah sorry Z2 the partial of Z2 with respect to X3 it's sort of depending on these
two pieces only and that's what you're achieving um by working out um the sort of outer product like that okay um yeah so let me just come back um one more time to um this the sort of question of the shape of derivatives um you know so I already sort of fudged it um when I was sort of um talking about oh should I put the the transpose there or should I nod and get a row vector is a column Vector um so there's sort of this disagreement between whether you kind of have the Jacobian form which is what actually makes the
chain roll work right in terms of doing multiplication um versus the shape convention which is how we store everything for our computations and Mak doing stochastic gradient descent where you're um subtracting um whatever kind of tensor you have easy um so um you know this can be a source of confusion um since we're doing a computer science course for the answers in the assignment we expect you to follow the shape convention so you know if you're working out the derivatives with respect to some Matrix it should be
shaped like a matrix with the same parameters um but you know you may well want to think about Jacobian forms and Computing your answers I mean there are sort of two ways to go about do doing this one way of doing it is to sort of work out all the math using Jacobian Al math 51 and at the end just to reshape it so it fits into the same shape as the parameters according to our shape convention I mean the other way is to sort of do each stage following the shape convention but then you sort of have to be game to sort of reshape
things as needed by sort of doing um transposing to have things work out at the different stages okay that was my attempt to quickly review the math most people are still here um I will now go on to the second half and go on to the um How We Do the computation right so you know so most of um yeah so the famous thing that powers new networks is the back propagation algorithm so the back propagation algorithm is really only two things you know its invention made people famous because it gave an effective learning
algorithm but you know at a fundamental level the back propagation algorithm is only two things thing one is you use the chain rule you do calculus of complex functions and Thing Two is um you store intermediate results so you never recompute the same stuff again that's all there is to the um back propagation algorithm and so let's just go through that so if we're computationally wanting to deal um with you know functions and doing back propagation we can think of them as being represented as a graph and in some
way or another um this kind of graph is being used inside your newal network framework so here is here is a re- representation of my little neural network for finding whether the word at the center is a location so I'm taking the X Vector input I'm multiplying it by W I'm adding B to it I'm putting it through the nonlinearity and then I'm um doing the dot product with my Vector U right so that was my computation and so the The Source nodes are the inputs in this graph the interior nodes then the
operations I do um and so then the edges that connect those together then pass along the result of each operation so I passed along WX to the addition function with B then I that gives me Z that I pass through the nonlinearity which gives me H which I then um dot product with the U to get S okay so I do precisely this computation and this is referred to as Ford propagation or the forward pass of a neural network so um the forward pass just calculates functions okay but then once we've done that what we want to
do is then work out gradients so we can do gradient based learning and so that part is then referred to as back propagation or the backward pass and then we run things backward so for running things backward we're going to use the same graph and we're going to backwards pass along at gradients and so we start at the right hand side and we have dsds so dsds is just one because you know um if you change S you've changed s and then what we want to do is sort of then work further back so we can
work out DSD ddz dsdb ddw dsdx as we work back um and so this is um the what we want to work out with gradients um and so how are we going to do that well if we look at a single node so for example our um our nonlinearity node but any node where H equal F ofx what we can have is an upstream gradient um DS DH and what we want to do is calculate the downstream gradient of the next variable down the D sdz and the way that we're going to do that is we're going to say well let's look at F what is F's gradient and
that's going to be our local gradient and then this is immediately what gives us the chain rule that D sdz is going to be the product of our Upstream gradient D sdh times the DHD Z the local um gradient that we calculate at that node so Downstream gradient equals um Upstream gradient times local gradient um oh yeah that's what that's what it says when I press um that again okay so this is the sort of the um single the single input single output case though those inputs might be vectors or
matrices or something like that um we then have sort of more complex graph cases um so I think I should have retitled this SL oh yeah so still so sorry so the next case is for our node it might have multiple inputs so this is where we're calculating WX so in that case we still have an up we have a single Upstream gradient and then what we're going to do is we want to calculate the downstream gradient with respect to each input and the way we're going to do that is we're going to
work out the local gradient with respect to each input and then we're going to do the same kind of multiplication of Upstream gradient times local gradient with respect to each input again um chain rule okay um so here's a little example of this so I'm this isn't really uh the kind of thing you normally see in a neural network but it's an easy example so F of XYZ is going to be x + y * the max of y z and we've got current values of X Y and Z of 1 2 and z respectively so here's our little computation graph
um and so for forward propagation you know we're going to do this addition we're going to do this Max function and then we're going to multiply the two and that gives us the value of f um so we can run that with the current values of X Y and Z and this is what we get so the max of two and 0 is two addition is three the answer is six okay so then after having done that we run the backward propagation and yeah so this procedure you know is not actually special to new networks right you can
use it for any piece of math if you want to just run your math um on pytorch rather than um working it out in your head or with Mathematica um okay so now we work out um backwards so we want to know the local gradient so d a DZ is going to be one sorry I said that wrong d a DX is going to be 1 so a = x + y d a d y = 1 um for the max function that's going to depend on which of the two is larger because it's going to have a slope of one for the one that's the biggest and zero for the one that's the smallest um and then
for the product that's like what we saw with vectors that dfda is going to be B and D FDB is going to be a um so those are all our local gradients and so then we can use those to calculate out the derivatives so dfdf is one um we then multiply that by the two um local gradients um that are calculated um for A and B so that gives us um two and three where you're swapping over the numbers then for the max um that we're having the one that is biggest um we're taking the Upstream times one so it gets
three the other one gets zero and then for the plus we're just sending the gradient down in both directions and so both of them come out as two um and so that gives us DF DX so the final function value is two D fdy we're taking the three and adding the two I'll mention that again in a minute which gives us five and then DFD Z is zero um and we should be able to again be able to quickly check that we've got this right right so um if we consider you know the slope around um Z as you change z a little so Z is Z if we
make Z 0.1 that makes absolutely no difference to what the computed function value is um so the gradient there is zero that's correct um so if I change up the Top If I change x a little bit right if I change X to 1.1 then I'll be calculating um 1.1 + 2 is 3.1 um and then I'll be taking the max which is two and I'll be calculating 5.1 um and so wait no I did that wrong oh times two wait I didn't do the multiplication right um sorry yeah so we get the 3.1 that's multiplied by two that gives us
6.2 so a change of 0.1 in the X has moved things up by 2 so that corresponds to the gradient being two and so then the final case is well what if we change y to um so y started off as two and made it 2.1 then we're going to get 2.1 multiplied by 1 is 2.1 61 6.5 and right and then we've got the 2.1 here the oh sorry I keep doing this wrong 2.1 + 1 = 3.1 and then we've got 2.1 as the max so we've got 2.1 * 3.1 and that comes out to be 6.51 so it's approximately gone up by so our 0.1 difference has gone up to
approximately 0.5 this is just an estimate um and so that correspond to the gradient being five right we get this five times multiplication of our changes okay um and so that that fact that illustrates the fact that the right thing to do is when you have outward branches in your um computation graph and you're running the um back propagation that what you do is you sum the gradients right um so that for this case we had y being um the Y is sort of going into these two different things in our previous chart so once we've worked
out the Upstream gradients we sum them to get the total gradient and so that's what we did back here we had two outward things and we sort of took these calculated Upstream gradients of two and three and we just summ them to get five and that gave the right answer okay um and so you can think about that um for the sort of just generally how the sort of things to think about as sort of gradients move around in these pictures so that when we have a plus operation that um plush just sort of distributes gradient so the same
gradient that's the Upstream gradient goes to each input um when you have a Max it's kind of like a router of gradient so the max is going to send the gradient to one of the inputs and send nothing at all to the other inputs um and when you have a multiplication it's a little bit funky because you're sort of um doing this sort of switching of the forward coefficient so you're taking the Upstream gradient multiplied by the opposite um for coefficient gives you your um Downstream
gradient okay um so we kind of have this systematic way of being able to sort of forward pass calculate the values of functions then run this backward to work out um the um gradients heading down the network and so the main other thing of the back propagation algorithm is just that we want to do this efficiently so the wrong way to do it would be to say well gee I want to calculate dstb ddw dsdx ddu so let me start doing those one at a time and when I've done them all I will stop because that means if
you first calculated dstb you do all of the part that's in blue um but then if you went on to DS DW um you'd be calculating all the part in red and well just as we saw in the math part when we were doing it as math um these parts are exactly the same you're doing exactly the same computations so you only want to do those that part once and work out this Upstream gradient or error signal that is being then sort of calculated and is then being shared so the picture that we want to have is you're doing together
the Shar part and then you're only sort of doing separately the little bits um that you need to do okay um boy I seem to have been rushing through today and I'm going to actually end early unless anyone is going to slow me down but I did have uh just a few more slides um to go through um yeah so the sort of generalization of this as an algorithm is you know in the general case you know so we normally have these sort of neural network layers and matrices which you can represent as vectors and
matrices um and you know it's sort of nice and clean and it looks like um doing that in Calculus class I mean strictly speaking that isn't necessary so the algorithm for forward propagation and backward propagation that I've outlined that you can have it work in a completely arbitrary comput ation graph providing it's a dag that doesn't have Cycles in it um so the general algorithm is well you've got a whole bunch of variables that depend on other variables there's some way in which we can sort
them so that each variable only depends on variables to the left of it so that's referred to as a topological sort of the outputs and so that means there's a way we can do a forward pass where we're calculating um variables in terms of ones that have already been calculated but you know if we want to have some extra wonky AR so it's not like nice Matrix multiplies or anything we're totally allowed to um do that or we can have things not fully connected right so there's no connections across here right
we can have an arbitrary computation graph um and so that gives us our forward propagation and then once we've done the forward propagation we can initialize the output gradient as as one and then we're going to visit the nodes in reverse order and at for each node we're going to compute a gradient by using the Upstream gradient and the local gradient to compute the downstream gradient and so then we can head back down the computation graph and work out all of the downstream gradients and so
the crucial thing to notice is that if you do it correctly um that working out um the the gradients has the same bigo complexity as working out the forward calculation right so that if you're doing more you know in if if in terms of Big O terms right you might have different functions depending on what the derivatives are but in bigo terms if you're doing more work in the backward path than you're doing in the forward paths that means that you're somehow failing to do this um efficient
computation and that you're recomputing some of your work okay um so because we have such a good algorithm here you should be able to just work out the backward path automatically and that that gets referred to as automatic differentiation so if you had the symbolic form of what you're calculating with your forward pass um you should just be able to say yo computer um can you work out the backward pass for me and you know kind of mathematical like it could look at the symbolic form of all of your
functions um work out their derivatives and do the entire thing for you um so early on there was a pioneering um deep learning framework theano principally from the um university of Montreal which attempted to do precisely that that you had the entire forward path computation started in symbolic form and it just did the entire thing for you and worked out the backward pass automatically um but you know somehow that sort of proved to be um too heavyweight or um hard to deal with different things or people just like to
write their own python or whatever it is um so that idea did not fully succeed and so what in practice all of the current main Frameworks have fallen back on is something that's actually less automated than that so it's sort of like we've gone backwards in time but the software's g a lot better really it's a lot staer and faster um so all of the modern deep learning Frameworks sort of say look I will manage the computation graph for you and I can run the forward propagation path and the backward
propagation path but you're going to have to work out the local um derivatives yourself um so if you're if you're putting in a layer or putting in um you know a function like an activation function in the in a neural network your class your python class that represents that you're going to have to tell me what the forward um computation is and what the local gradient is and I'm just going to call your local gradient and assume it's correct um so there's a bit more that
has to be done manually so so the part that's automated then um is that you know when you know precisely this code obviously but roughly you know inside the Deep learning software um it's Computing with a computation graph and it's got a forward and a backward and it's doing what I presented on the pictures before so for the forward um pass it's topologically sorting all the nodes of the graph and then it's going through them and for each node in the graph it's calling its forward function
which will be able to compute its local value in terms of its inputs which have already been calculated because it's topologically sorted and then it's um running the backward pass and in the backward pass you're reversing your topological sort and then you're working out um the gradient which is going to be the multiplication of the Upstream error signal times your local gradient and so what a human being has to implement um is that for anything whether it's a single gate here's a multiply gate or a
newal network layer you have to implement a forward pass and a backward pass so here for my baby example since we're just doing multiplication my forward pass is that I just multiply the two numbers and um return it so I'm specifying that for the local node and then the other part is that I have to work out those gradients and well we sort of know how to do that because that's the examples that we've been doing here um but notice that there's sort of a trick right for what I've got
Now you kind of can't write down what the gradients are cuz you know what these cuz you know backward is just taking as an input the Upstream gradient and you can't work out what the downstream gradient are going to be unless you know what function values you're calculating it at um so the standard trick that all which is how everyone writes this code is you're relying on the fact that the forward is being calculated before the backward and so your forward method um shoves into some local variables of the class what
the values of the inputs are and then you have them available um so when you get to the back backward pass you can do what we did before um that um the DX is going to be the Upstream error signal times the opposite input and um and similarly for Dy and that's going to give us the answer okay um just two last things then to mention yeah so doing this um your you need to write um you need to get the math right for what's the derivative of your function so you get the right backward calculation so the
standard way to check that you've got the right backward calculation is to do manual gradient checking um with numeric gradients so the way you do that um is you sort of like for the couple of examples I did when I said oh let's check it by for going from 1 to 1.1 what should the slope be approximately we're going to do that in an automated way and so we're going to say at the value X let's estimate what the gradient should be and the way to do that is to pick a small H there isn't a magical number because it
depends on the function but typically you know for neural networks around 10us 4 is good um a small H and work out the function value I forward part at x + H and x - H divided by the run which is 2 H and that should give you an estimate of the slope what the backward pass is calculating and you want those two numbers to be approximately equal you know within some 10us 2 of each other and then probably you're calculating the gradient right and if they aren't equal um that um you probably have made a mistake um yeah so
um note that this formul for the version I did for my examples I just compared to x with x + H right I did a one-sided estimate which is normally what you get taught in a math class if you're doing this to check your gradients numerically you're far far better off doing this two-sided estimate because it's much more accurate and stable when you're doing it equally around both sides of your H um yeah so this looks easy to do um if if this was just so good why doesn't everyone do this all the time
and forget about calculus um you know the reason you don't want to do this is that doing this is incredibly slow right because you have to repeat this computation for every parameter of your model that you're not getting the kind of speed UPS your getting from the um back propagation algorithm but you know it's useful for checking your implementation is correct you know in the old days before Frameworks like py torch um you know we used to write everything by hand and people often got
things wrong um but nowadays you know it's less needed but it's good to check that if you've implemented your own new layer that it's doing the right thing okay um yeah so that's everything that we need to know about new Nets propagation is the chain rule applied efficiently forward pass is just function application backward pass is chain rule applied inefficiently um so you know uh we're going to inflict pain on our students by making them do some math and calculate some of these things
and um do the homework and I know that'll be harder for some of you than others um you know that in some sense you don't actually need to know how to do this the beauty of these modern deep learning Frameworks is they'll do it all for you they predefine common layer types and you can just plug them together like pieces of Lego and they'll be computed right and this is precisely the reason that high school students across the country and the world can now do deep learning projects for their
science fairs because you don't actually have to understand any of this math um you can just use what's given to you um but you know um we kind of uh want to hope that you actually do understand something about what's going on under the hood and how new networks work so therefore we make you suffer a little bit and of course you know if you sort of wanting to look at and understand more complex things you need to have some sense of what's going on so later on when we get on to a current new
networks we'll talk a bit about things like exploding and Vanishing great and if you want to have some understanding about well why things aren't working and things are going wrong um then you sort of want to know what it's actually calculating rather than just thinking it's all a black box magic and so that's why we hope to have uh taught something about that okay I think I'm done if the audience is sufficiently stunned um and we can stop for today okay thank you